that study that was done
by the by cambridge there's a couple
researchers from cambridge
where they studied the brain activity
between drug addicts and
people who were porn addicts and they
compared they compared them to
healthy volunteers whatever and they
noticed that there was the three regions
in the brain that like lit up
and it was almost identical between the
drug addicts and the porn addicts
yeah it affected them the same way it
could be treated as an
addiction yeah and the crazy part about
it was they even went deeper to find out
why don't humans stop doing something
when they know
that it's either physically or
psychologically damaging to them
and the part about like how it's not
you're doing something
despite the fact that you'd like you
don't even like it
yeah bring it yeah compulsive behavior
like it was just like smoking cigarettes
or overeating or snorting coke
or any of those things you know that
they're terrible for you and they could
kill you but you still do it anyways
and that speaks so much to how
like how this material would like how it
actually affects the brain like how
how similar to drugs it really is
because the brain can't really tell the
difference because i mean we have one
reward system that's all we got
you know so that reward system can be
hijacked by basically
anything that will give you pleasure but
then obviously
you know we are going to be like more
we're going to experience more
um you know a more um
you know a greater high more kicks we're
going to get more kicks out of watching
porn
than you know taking walks or whatever
you know like it's
and the same with coking you know that's
going to be more effective
when it comes to getting you hooked than
let's say other more you know
yeah weed or whatever so yeah
and another thing to consider is
you know they're swiping through tinder
and they're not thinking clearly because
they want to find sex or they're super
horny and they want to get with somebody
who they may not like or they may not
they may not love they may not even
like them but they think they're hot
because they're super horny
and they're not thinking clearly because
of that so maybe they should just
watch some porn and get it out of their
system right that's another thing to
consider
yeah sure that's why a lot of people
could end up in relationships
in relationships with people they don't
like or they don't love
what because because because
they're both they both just love sex
and they both provide that reward for
each other
but they may not love each other they
just ended up in that situation because
it was convenient for both of them
right right okay yeah because you don't
you don't really think clearly
when you're when you're when you have
that energy and you're like
super all you're thinking about is sex i
mean that happens to everybody
so when you do that you don't think
rationally
right and you you end up in those
relationships like that and you realize
20 years down the road [ __ ] we don't
even like each other right
we just like to [ __ ] right
right that makes sense it's important
yeah for sure yeah
yeah yeah so so instead of
johnny going out on a hundred tinder 100
tinder dates in a year
and risk risking catching an std instead
he just wants to watch some porn and get
it out of his system
sure it's a it's another thing to
consider
i mean yeah sure i've heard that you
know a lot um
then i would say to johnny like dude
there are more options than
you know a careless relationship for 20
years or porn like
right yeah you have some other things
you can choose between as well
it's not your only two options yeah yeah
if i'm gonna like be you know uh let me
be tough on you then and say like
is it because if that's the cure to
unhealthy relationship if that if the
cure is porn
you know i mean
wouldn't then the pouring problem be
fixed once you have a good relationship
are you know are there no people in good
relationships consuming pouring
you'd want to connect with them on more
levels than
sex yeah yeah and a lot of people
especially kids
teenagers people in their in their in
their 20s
they're not thinking like that they're
just thinking with that one part of
their brain
and if you could sort of get that out of
the way
it changes your thinking you believe
that
yeah 100 percent i believe yeah uh-huh
okay explain that one more time like
what what are you actually saying
what are you thinking that porn can kind
of cure i don't think it's necessarily
porn itself that can cure that
but what i'm saying is people that you
think are hot and you think you like
because you're being blinded by
horniness or whatever you want to call
it instead you just
watch some porn and you masturbate and
instantly that feeling is gone right and
now you're like what was i thinking
why would i i don't even like this
person right like
i just wanted to have sex i wanted to
get that out of my system yeah
i think a lot of people deal with that
problem yeah for sure like i hear that
all the time
and not saying porn is the answer i'm
not definitely not saying porn is the
answer but it's obviously
it's it's the easiest solution right
it's the most obvious thing to go to
it's so available to you yeah and like
there are different factors to that like
one
for sure that can be true uh the other i
would say to just consider
is to also like um
again like are those two two the only
two options that you have
you know are there other ways to kind of
enhance your life
and to like use your use your
imagination
yeah or just like read a book
like there are other things we can do
but also there's a fact of like
because that has to be considered as
well obviously um
if what we were saying uh earlier about
um you know the backgrounds when it
comes to people in porn
if that in fact is the case like is that
fair to like have a group of people
that we can kind of like take our urges
out on
you know what i mean explain that one
more time so instead of me going out and
having
you know sex with 100 different peoples
via tinder
i'm gonna go online and you know jerk
off to some porn
but then i'm what i'm saying is that is
that fair to people important to like
have that you know have a group of
people that you're like it's fine
if you're important you know you can be
important for my sake you know
yeah i understand what you're saying are
we kind of ready like do we want to like
sacrifice this group of people
since we do know the backgrounds they
come from like are we like okay with
you know what i mean using them for our
own
you know um yeah
salvation kinder yeah i yeah
i know i know what you mean but it's
kind of like
it's the the way society works and it's
the way the world works those people
are there because they're desperate
i feel like people become porn stars
because they're desperate in the
situation where they
they finally make that leap right now
not just porn stars
strippers or prostitutes right they're
desperate
for something and the most obvious way
to get
independence and to get financial
success
at that moment would be porn or
prostitution
or dancing at a strip club right
um you know the obviously there's a lot
of long-term
a long-term long-term negative effects
to it
and it comes with that you know people
you're going to have kids jerking off to
your videos for years
and your kids when you have kids and
they go to high school they're
middle school you're going to have all
their friends asking you about
their your mom and why they're all
watching your mom
right have sex on their iphones so you
know i don't think they think about that
they don't think about that in the
moment right
in that moment they're desperate for
money or they're desperate for
independence and that's the answer
that's the easiest answer that's also
like interesting because i i
you know we do have i would say like we
we do have somewhat of you know a porn
culture
in a way like it's like we were saying
earlier like it's leaking into different
parts of society it's leaking into media
advertisement
the fitness industry like all of that
and so
i find it i find it just like
interesting like we do have this culture
um where
you know some people are gonna be pushed
into the porn industry or into other
types of prostitution or
you know and but once they're in it
like we're gonna judge them you know
what i mean
then we're going to be like oh like
you're going to be online forever
like obviously you're going to be online
forever and but i'm like
what i'm trying to say is that um
the society kind of opened that door
but once they entered we're you know
we're willing to use
porn but we're also judging the people
in porn
right you know so that's kind of what i
i think it's so important because i do
that's what i've heard so many people
that i've talked to in the industry say
that
um like this girl actually told me she
was like you're actually the first one
to uh ask me to to talk about this
because i just read tweets and you know
whatever about me but no way
nobody ever comes to me and actually
asks these questions
and she was really like explaining to me
how she was really feeling
uh judged really by society but it's
also the same society that will go
behind closed doors and watch her you
know what i mean
so when i'm talking about porn i'm very
much talking about it from a stand point
of us
and i'm on their side
yeah you know like yeah totally yeah so
i'm like looking to look at how did you
end up here like
but again i'm also i think it's
like we gotta take it one step further
and not just look at
um why and how people ended up important
but also to see like
who are you know who are the consumers
what is happening in society
what kind of attitudes are we kind of
adapting
from using aggressive porn and all of
that
so it's really we gotta have all the all
the pieces